Elon Musk also runs the world's biggest
rocket company so we couldn't resist
asking him about aliens of course we did
[Music]
a lot of people ask me you know
um
where are the aliens and I I think if
anyone would know about aliens on Earth
that would probably be me I would think
yeah I'm you know very familiar with
space stuff
tomorrow night his full answer on that
and also his views on why civilizations
rise and why they fall and what we can
do about it Elon Musk is famously
decided to help repopulate the Earth
himself we're going to tell you his
thinking behind that or rather he will
explain it a fascinating second part of
our interview with Elon Musk tomorrow
night right here at 8pm Eastern we've
got a new documentary by the way on Fox
News you should call it the meat bugs
just in case you're wondering what
happens to your tax dollars
they're sending it to scientists to
create a tastier cockroach
that's on Fox Nation subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight